well our political correspondent rob
powell is in westminster for us now and
rob the list of candidates keep growing
nine so far and the foreign secretary
liz truss is expected to also launch her
bid within the next 24 hours it's
starting to look very crowded
yeah i think it's been known for some
time
months in fact i'd say that liz trusts
would be having a go at the top job when
a vacancy
came free we understand she will
officially launch her campaign in the
next 24 hours one of her allies simon
clark the treasury minister has been in
the sunday papers today as good as
setting out some of liz truss's pledges
uh and the pledges that we're getting
from her team today are pretty similar
to what we're hearing from almost all of
the other leadership candidates and it's
the t word tax almost a race to see who
can put forward um the most um tax cuts
you heard tom tugan hat there in that
interview with sophie ridge
talking about cutting national insurance
and fuel duty he's long been a critic of
that national insurance rise that is of
course the tax rise that came in in
april that will be rebranded the health
and social care levy um next year
essentially initially paying to fund the
nhs and to help with covert backlogs and
then we'll go into funding reforms into
um social care controversial when it was
brought through
uh many privately in the conservative
party were unhappy and it seems that
that unhappiness is now breaking out
into the open because we've also had
sajid javid who was in fact health
secretary when that tax to pay for
health care and social care was brought
in so sat there and presumably yes voted
for it now saying that he would reverse
it and it's not something he would have
done if he was chancellor uh liz trust
as well saying that she would reverse
the national insurance rise grant shaps
not talking about that but talking about
income tax and bringing forward a one
penny income tax cut jeremy hunt as you
heard in that clip talking more about
business taxes and corporation tax
that's something that's also been
focused on by other leadership
contenders other people like nadeem
zahari and suella braveman have also
made a big play for their tax cutting
credentials now why are they doing this
well i think the strategy is on this
part anyway that because they are
appealing not necessarily to the general
public but to tory mps and tory members
the the logic is
if you say you'll cut taxes then you'll
get votes well yes to an extent but i
think competence also matters in all of
this that's to say i think the people
voting the rank and file tory card
carrying members around the country have
got to believe that you're able to make
your sums add up and that you can pay
for some of these tax rises and bluntly
we're already hearing quite a lot of
shade thrown on some of these claims the
ifs the institute for fiscal studies
which is pretty down the line on this
sort of stuff a team of economists that
scrutinizes the government's work its
boss paul johnson has already said today
that if we are going to have tax cuts of
some of these levels then people need to
be honest that it means things like
public pay not keeping up with rising
prices so real terms cuts for people
that work in the public sector or it
means more borrowing which would go
against potentially conservative
manifesto
promises i think as well what appeals to
conservative party members and mps
doesn't necessarily win votes in the
broader public and i think whilst you
can make a pretty good argument for
cutting business taxes and corporation
tax if the first thing a new prime
minister did in the middle of a cost of
living crisis was dropped taxes for
businesses i think bluntly the labour
party would be licking their lips at
that prospect in terms of new entrants
we've had today penny mordant an
international trade minister has become
the ninth person to enter the race she's
posted quite a patriotic video um online
on twitter saying it needs to be
less about the leader and more about the
ship penny morton of course has a
military
background she's also been quite keen to
get on the front foot
and dispel as she sees it anyway some
issues around sort of identity politics
and gender identity that she has come
under fire for um in the past as i say a
tenth candidate liz trust will likely
announce in the next 24 hours expect as
well as tax another big issue to
potentially be
the candidates relationships and how
close they were with boris johnson we're
already starting to get a sense of that
in the interviews this morning jeremy
hunt being pretty clear about um his uh
distaste shall we say for the pr for the
current interim prime minister uh on the
way out um in the coming weeks grant
shaps on the other hand talking up uh
essentially boris johnson and saying his
problem may have been that he was too
loyal and talking up essentially his
credentials as someone that stuck with
the prime minister and didn't spend a
lot of time plotting now i think we are
certainly going to get to 10 candidates
there have been people tweeting support
for the home secretary pretty patel
overnight so we may well go even higher
than 10 it will be for senior
conservative mps that set the rules on
this leadership race tomorrow to decide
whether they want to tighten the rules
and compress the leadership contest to
try and whittle those candidates down to
two in a quick way